Speaker 1: All right, welcome to the show.
We are going to be admittedly taking a tour
today through some really depressing and horrible
realities about what's going on in the country
in terms of the fragmentation or Balkanization,
as we might call it, of the American right
wing.
There's going to be a lot of really horrible
and negative things we talk about.
But I think it's important, No.
One, not to lose sight of the bigger picture.
And number two, to also be a little bit less
depressed to start with what is actually some
good news, not only about the pandemic, which
I'll get to in a moment, but about the direction
of the country and the majority of the country
understanding that this change that took place
between the last administration and the current
one, it's not trivial.
It's not irrelevant.
It's really having an impact on people.
We have new data from an NBC News poll that
shows that the percentage of Americans who
say the country is, generally speaking, going
in the right direction has just about doubled
since Donald Trump left office in January,
the day after Joe Biden was inaugurated.
So January 21st, only 20 percent of the country
believed that the United States was, quote,
headed in the right direction, which is often
the way this question is asked in polling.
But that share has improved to 40 percent
among adults during the period April 17 to
20.
And it's it's actually a crazy reality where
we say, hey, 40 percent of the country, just
just more than a third, 40 percent of the
country now thinks we are going in the right
direction.
And this is a massive increase and we should
see that as a really good thing.
I understand that that's a depressing and
incredibly low bar.
But understand that, first of all, if you
thought the country was going in the right
direction under Donald Trump, your disconnect
from the real world is so significant that
it's not that reasonable to think all of those
people are going to have some awakening once
just a normal person takes control of the
Oval Office.
And the sad reality is that that perspective
that the right direction was the one under
Donald Trump remains the case for tens of
millions of Americans, and that's not going
to change anytime soon.
So when we look at these numbers, if you showed
these numbers to people from many other countries
and you said, listen, we had arguably the
most destructive and unhinged president in
the modern political era, and at that time,
20 percent of the country thought we were
going in the right direction.
We removed him.
His party lost the house in twenty eighteen.
His party lost the Senate in twenty twenty
as well.
We have someone who now has built one of the
best vaccination distribution programs in
the world, and Joe Biden, who passed covid
stimulus and is on the path to doing some
other things.
We're doing great now.
Oh, and we still only have 40 percent of the
country believing that we are now going in
the right direction.
Other countries would look at that and they
would I don't know if they would laugh or
cry or feel pity or be scared or whatever
the case may be.
But it certainly wouldn't make a lot of sense.
So there is no question that there's a long
way to go.
There is no question, no question that the
hyper partizanship that we're experiencing
is going to create.
I mean, listen, the I don't think in modern
American political space, you would ever have
80 percent of the country say we are now going
in the right direction for partizan reasons,
for tribal reasons, et cetera.
Let's take some solace because there's a lot
of really bad stuff we're going to be going
over today.
I'm warning you about that in the fact that
it has doubled and then the continued good
news as far as the pandemic goes, the continued
improving jobs numbers and stock market numbers
and remaining low inflation over the next
six to eight months hopefully will increase
those numbers even further.
Now, from the standpoint of just understanding
the Trump perspective on this question, where
are we going in the right direction then?
Are we going in the right direction?
Now, Trump supporters seem unable to just
accept the reality that Trump was historically
unpopular.
Trump never hit 50 percent approval.
He left with twenty nine percent approval.
And Joe Biden is relatively popular given
the polarized nature of the country, mid to
high 50s approval for a president in the modern
political era dating back to, you know, the
George W. Bush era.
It's significant in that it's not that common.
Trump live by anecdote.
I don't know.
I went to a Trump rally and everybody there
had a Trump flag.
And also, when I look on Twitter, Joe Biden
doesn't get that many re tweets on Twitter.
They're anecdotal experience.
Plus watching what Newsmax and Fox News tell
them, tells them it can't possibly be true
that the country is now more optimistic that
Biden has higher approval than Trump.
Trump losing in 20 to.
He was proof of how bad of a candidate he
was, he was gifted a crisis that for many
other world leaders, proper handling of the
pandemic easily escorted them to a just completely
runaway reelection.
Trump had the incumbency advantage.
He had voter suppression on his side, and
he still managed to lose.
People point to look at how many votes Trump
was able to get, but they don't seem to realize
the number of people that were alienated by
Trump and horrified by Trump led to record
votes for Joe Biden as well.
And only half of that story seems to be what
they focus on.
This is a No. 20 percent to 40 percent
going
in the right direction.
That, if
it continues, is
a good sign.